[Music]
247 debt free screams on the air this
year this is a slow year because of
covid
uh the lobby was shut down here and uh
we spent a month and a half not doing
debt free scrims just taking calls from
people that were struggling
with getting laid off and all the
craziness with the lockdown back in the
spring so
debt-free screams were suspended for a
little while so it's an unusually low
year usually kelly they're about
45 to 50 million a year roughly is that
about right
that's about right and debt free screams
a total for the year
of the people doing the screaming this
year it's going to be a little less it's
going to be about 28 million
184 in the lobby 63 on the phone
heavy lobby screams though go figure
and um uh average debt paid off per
caller this is interesting this one this
is numbers i haven't seen before
uh take the average of you know per debt
free screamer
there's a hundred and fourteen 000
average
time that they took to pay off their
debt 30.14 months
we had 18 ramsey team members who did
debt-free screams
uh totaling a million four that's cool
41 states and two canadian provinces
were represented in the debt-free
screamers california
18 florida 17 texas 16 illinois 14
indiana
13 ohio 12 pennsylvania 11 and tennessee
10 that's the top
10 of the 167 or the 6 was 167 that what
i said it was
a 247 yeah okay and uh
and he goes month by month through the
whole thing and of course we see the
drop off
uh there in april when there was almost
no debt-free screams and that dropped us
behind our averages but that's
interesting 114 over 30 months
all over the united states and 114 000
average so that kind of gives you guys
that are working on your debt snowball
some encouragement to get through it and
um
we have this little stage here the debt
free stage it's waiting on you
two and a half years so over 30 years
dave what is the secret ben somebody
gets fired up they take off sprinting
them and their husband take off
sprinting through the woods
like a good gazelle three months in
what's the shot in the arm that's going
to go two and a half two and a half
years is a long time and i'm thinking
through it like
fixing your marriage fixing your your
relationship with your parents i'm
thinking that like weight loss
i know the stats there two and a half
years is a season that's a long long
time
uh the motivation shifts on the ones
that make it
okay when people start out they start
all of us do this me include you
included we start out
like a cold shower just screaming
braveheart
right a cold shower screaming braveheart
no i'm talking about
that on a t-shirt you know what i'm
talking about you just gotta run it's
gonna grind i'm just gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna
i'm just gonna run into this concrete
block wall until it falls over that's
right
right and and that gets you started that
sets a new groove in your brain
it causes you to sell the car have a
garage sale sell so much stuff the kids
are next stay out of restaurants
you know take the extra job it causes
you to do the stuff right
to get moving and that will last 90 days
some people can do it for nine months
mine is about 90 days about three months
very few people can do that for a year
they're very very unusual it's a
psychological disorder if you could do
it here
i mean i mean it's just just the just
the sheer raw
emotion the guttural scream right but
what happens is as they start to win
they start to believe and it's not just
this
sheer desperation sheer anger sheer
disgust raw emotion that's driving them
now it starts to be hope hope that i'm
really going to get out
and when you start to believe then you
start to look past the debt
and go i'm going to change my family
tree i'm doing
this for these babies i'm looking at and
that's a different kind of emotion
that's not a screaming braveheart
emotion
that comes deep from within that's the
kind of emotion you die for that's right
that's the kind of honor nobility
dignity change my family tree higher
calling
i want to be generous like i've never
been before and the emotion starts to
come from caring for others rather than
self
gods and when it shifts off of you that
90-day nine-month mark six-month mark
whatever it is
that's the ones that complete if you
just keep it on you
i want to be rich to be rich for me
because i'm richie rich and i want to
have the bling
and i want to have the car that's a
hollow hollow light shallow and there's
not a lot of energy in it that's right
and it runs out it runs out people don't
make it selfish motivation in other
words they'll get you started
but it won't keep you going there's a
switch that flips
it's not a switch it's go over the hill
whatever it is like it's a smooth or
it's rough or whatever but you go over
and all of a sudden there's a green
valley and it's all about others
and it's a godly man leaves an
inheritance to his children's
children i i remember having the thought
i'm going to make so much money if my
kids are screw up so they can't go
through it all
huh and that means the kids the
grandkids are going to have something
yup you know and i didn't want to do
that i really didn't want to be
screw-ups and i wasn't going to leave
money if they were screw-ups that's
dysfunctional
but i remember having the mathematical
thought of
i mean you really i mean you think about
standard oil you know jp morgan those
guys
and they made so much money that four
generations later they still can't go
through it they can't burn through it
they still can't go through it
and it's ruined some of them some of
them didn't make it you know and and
i remember i remember when they became
trust fund babies but with a workout
plan
when i went from yeah i want to look
great to
from vanity i want to be able to roll
around on the floor with my grandkids
and then suddenly you get up every
morning yeah
right from vanity to uh i want the pants
the legacy yep to i am tired of being
tired
when i'm playing with my three-year-old
two my
son got quarantined and had to do a
couple of uh
weeks at home on a zoom class
and dave we don't talk about it it's not
something that we beat in it's just
something
you get up every day and we're going to
be stewards of our body we're going to
take care of ourselves
and he said i've got to go sprint dad
and he walked out the door and took off
running down the driveway and i thought
that's how legacy change happens not by
barking and yelling but
we're going to do it we're going to do
it and then this christmas it's been
i think my sister's really going to love
this gift this is this is when it turned
it's not about what am i going to get
what am i going to get it's
hey can we go can we go to the store one
more time get something for mom right
and it starts to shift so maturity and
it's just
it's just a nickel and a diameter
neckline a dime it's maturity and it's
by degrees
and that's why i say it's not all of a
sudden you're going along in braveheart
cold water mode
and then you just switch to noble
grandpa that's not it doesn't happen in
one fell thing
but there is a movement in the spirit to
where and i think it
is associated with hope when you first
start you're not sure this is going to
work
i'm just going i got to do something
something's got to change
i got to bust into this but then when
you knock off and you go man i paid off
those first six deaths in that that
snowball this the snowball's actually
rolling
and the concrete really the evidence in
front of me indicates that i should have
hope those steps get firmer right yeah
and then you're like
that gum now we can run baby we're doing
this man game on
game on baby you know and and all of a
sudden that hope kicks in hope deferred
makes the heart sick
but when desire comes it is the tree of
life